hallo mein name ist super und herzlich
willkommen zu einer bienen basel jelly
beans challenge zusammen mit max mein
name ist mein name ist
ich war letztes in berlin und habe mir
dort diese jelly beans gekauft es ist
einfach so ein spiel wo man quasi diese
bestimmte anzahl von verschiedenen
ebenen hat und man muss dann hier bei
dem rädchen drehen da kommt dann eine
wohl raus und die muss dann dagegen über
essen
es gibt wirklich das ganze ist kein
statement
falls es irgend jemand denken sollte
aber sie sagen mensch und ich denke wir
werden vier spieler nachts erfassen oder
ich sehe hier ist kopfe hier ist windeln
popel hier sind hundefutter babywindeln
wir machen das ganze jetzt so dass ich
beispielsweise für max drehe er hatte
dabei die augen
ich gebe ihnen das ding da muss dann
erraten was es ist und das richtig errät
kriegt einen punkt an das falsche
richtern keinen punkt und jeder macht
das halb fünf mal und wer dann am ende
die meisten punkte hat dem anderer
stelle geben
wir fangen jetzt an okay leute wir haben
was und wie lang kann man noch so eine
wohnung kaufen ich kenne den geschmack
aber ich kann es gar nicht zuordnen ist
auch etwas gutes
kokosnuss jessens mit all der name weist
also wenn es jetzt in den windeln
geschmeckt hat es hat definitiv möglich
doch erst gar nicht auseinander das
heißt ich habe jetzt einen punkt und max
jetzt an der reihe ich durch regel
wieder ganz schön und wir haben hier
will man auch die bohne von vorhin und
jetzt für das rad rhein fand ich auch
unter
die 2008er fast eingeloggt meine damen
und herren also als auflösung würde ich
sagen es war entweder hoch oder gcp und
ich doch nach erfolgter definitiv buckel
und das heißt es steht immer noch 1 0
für mich und meine stehen aber nicht
gescheitert ist die top blogger
mein gott ich kann mich nicht
entscheiden zwischen tierkadaver oder
mutter erde mit scheiße gemüse des
berichts widerlich sachen hundekot hunde
für hundefutter waren ist auch dass ich
das auf essen obwohl er natürlich müssen
jetzt bin ich dann fackelt ekelhaft man
diese jelly bean muss max essen die
auswahl bestand zwischen 40 und kotze
und gehört definitiv kurze gezogen wird
schmeckt ich hatte auch schon mal kurz
davor mit gästen wie damals du musst es
unterschiedlich
ich hatte davon vorher schon sein zwei
stück gegessen wenn man eigentlich kann
und es schmeckt wirklich genau also
wirklich hat braucht wissen und das hat
sie extra geschmack bereit machen immer
wenn ich jemanden brechen gesehen und
musste mich auch über ihn und es richtig
auf meinen und noch kurz aber wie
kriegst du es auch irgendwas abgefuckt
du hast ein punkt bekommen meine damen
das ist der erste punkt für max täglich
täglich für die kurze gelacht als
unfassbar ist keine katze ist auch kein
hundefutter ungekürzte ich sagt
babywindel nicht erfreut ist weiß ich
brauchte fast 80 leute der mess halbzeit
haben fünf mal gedreht ich drehe jetzt
für max und zwar muss macht könnte macht
es einen hinweis geben aber wir sind
komplett verarschen
ich hab einfach gedreht ich hab einfach
gedreht und die gäste auch hier sieht
sein könnten
trotzdem sage ich es richtig ja zwei zu
eins für max wo genau wie götze 29
gebaut wieder gerne kleine änderung
und zwar wird der verlierer nicht nur
eine stelle kriegen sondern hält wird
fünf unterschiedliche farbige jelly
beans essen die halt fünf eklige sachen
auf einmal sein
und das wäre ziemlich jetzt steht aber
noch 22 ich drehe jetzt für max wenn
jetzt kommt dann breche ich ab wirklich
ich bin raus hier muss max jetzt mag
macht dann muss ich zeigen die kameras
nicht in den mund
nachdem auf keiner kennt würde ich mal
nicht so was der christus erstmals ist
dieser candy gesprochen gibt also das
heißt tutti frutti aber ich würde mal
sagen das ist candy es ist halt kelly
geschmack ich weiß nicht ob du scheinst
du schmeckst lecker wenn es nicht ihn
flanz voraussagen ganze also entweder es
wird die foto- oder stinkesocken politik
bestimmt die couch tut die kunden mit
einer pflanze verleger von den werten
genau das gleiche hintereinander zeiger
steht auf dieser sache und max mich also
diese frucht hier essen
in paris fiel ich das gleiche wie
mandarinen ist nicht okay kein punkten
entweder gleich lukas und wir müssen
jetzt stechen gehen
oder er wird jetzt verpackt man darf
erst am vortag nicht gebraucht noch
gebrauchen beiden noch eingeflogen
das ist richtig
limette falsch zitiert ich habe teile
muss ich jetzt in den mund nehmen ja
vorne das was hier mit der jelly beans
challenge wo wir verschiedene teile von
den gästen haben und der rat muss das so
sein sollte und ich musste am ende fünf
stück auf einmal essen wenn ich das
ganze gefallen hat und je mehr bock auf
600 lasten daumen hoch das ist max der
muss jetzt sein zu kriegen und der
essener beschreibungen drin
baku hütet als neues war nicht cool
wegen es hat wehgetan und